so we're here to talk about clustering
sessions
application sessions on top of cassandra
my name is les hazlet i'm the
cto and co-founder of storm path we were
disrupting the identity management space
this in turn has a session id generator
so as when new sessions are created
um clearly a new identifier needs to be
associated with them
um this could be anything it could be a
string it could be a long for like
relational databases
given that this is a cassandra group and
we'll be using cassandra as a back end
you can create for example a time uuid
uh generator that will generate timely
uids every time a new session is created
and then that of course could be the
roki that you store that will store a
session underneath
or store a session in cassandra with but
more on that later
um there's also a session cache so
we don't always want to be pinging or
kind of hammering the data store every
time we do crud operations
so there is a cache that is shared by
all application instances so we have
second level caching
kind of plugins built in so people use
hazelcast or
clustered get our ehcash with terracotta
or gigaspaces or coherence you know
basically redis it doesn't matter you
could plug in any
any number of second level caches and
then finally
there's the data store under the hood
behind you know behind the session cache
and of course in in this case we're
going to be using cassandra
um so the purple kind of the purple uh
objects on this diagram are really all
related to persistence
or crud for given session objects in
addition there is a session validation
scheduler
that the session manager uses to make
sure that sessions
when they expire they are deleted from
the data store
or when they're known to have been
expired or when they expire
immediately kind of remove them from the
data store but this is really important
every single session management
mechanism out there
tomcats jetties doesn't matter they all
have one of these things
and it's necessary necessary to make
sure the session orphans
don't fill up the data store over time
so like if you're using a web
application and you know that
application has created a session for
you
you just close the browser and you don't
you don't click log out or anything like
that your session's still alive it still
exists somewhere in a data store
and if something like a scheduler didn't
exist
all those orphan sessions that no longer
have
users using them will just fill up the
data store over time so you need
something
to remove sessions from the data store
and
the session validation scheduler is the
thing that shiro uses to do that
and then of course their session
listener so you can have
register many different session
listeners to determine
you know life cycle or be notified of
life cycle events so session started a
session stopped it's expired it's
deleted
you can kind of react to these events in
your application and perform
operations so this is the
the architecture of sessions or excuse
me shiro's session management slice of
the whole framework
any questions about this before we start
talking about cassandra's specifics
everybody on the same page how this
works
okay all right so
we're just going to focus now on just
the purple parts
so just the uh the
how do we how do we configure shiro to
represent these things in its
configuration
such that we can point to cassandra as
the data store
and we'll use a web application a
configuration in this
in this kind of example um again as i
mentioned you can use shiro in any kind
of different
jvm context we've got again people using
it in command line apps we have people
using it in vertex which is an
asynchronous framework
akka play so there's all sorts of kind
of
environments that you would configure
shirow in and
in those environments you might have
different environment specific
configuration techniques
but we'll just focus on the the standard
servlet web application model here
with shiro's web config it's just a
couple things that you drop in
web xml and shiro will then protect
all urls or any any kind of request
that flows through the application will
be intercepted by shiro on all of them
and make security decisions as to
whether or not the request is allowed to
continue or not so
maybe a certain part of the application
is supposed to only be accessed if
you're authenticated
or if there's a known user identity
shiro will make these decisions
before they ever hit your application
code and either send a response back or
redirect to a login screen what have you
there's
all sorts of behaviors that you can
support
in your application because shiro is
filtering all requests
there's some really cool innovative
filtering url filter definitions that
shiro has
configuring servlet filters in web.xml
is not very nice
especially if you have a decent number
of them cheryl makes this actually much
much easier
via a custom dsl and of course as you
might expect there are jsp
tag tag libraries support jsf tag
library support so you can
show or not show things within the jsp
or jsf page based on
security state of the current user and
as i mentioned
transparent http session support
so this is how you enable shiro in a web
app
every shiro deployment needs an
environment
and so this listener will listen for the
servlet context of startup
create a new environment instance a
shiro environment
and then bind it to the servlet context
so that environment is tied
to that particular deployed application
and you can deploy many different
environments
it's almost always a one-to-one
correlation so you have one environment
per deployed web application
and then once the environment listener
is deployed or excuse me defined
um you you then specify the shiro filter
that will then use this environment in
order to filter
all requests and get access to all the
security things that it needs to do
to get this job done in addition to the
filter
as part of the filter definition rather
you've got to specify a mapping
that says i want to i want to filter
every single request that goes through
the app that's the slash
star i want the shiro filter to handle
it and all of these
request types should uh should be
processed by sheryl again this is just
kind of setting up the overhead of of
telling
the web container to to let everything
flow through shiro so it can make
security decisions and of course
session session operations once that's
done
instead of embedding all these security
rules and configuration into web.xml
which is very nice
um you can configure shiro in a number
of ways
out of the box shiro comes with a an
ini-based configuration mechanism
that um that supports what we like to
call as poor man's dependency injection
you'll see very soon that you can create
object graphs just by simple dot
notation
and so this is the out of the box
default lowest common denominator format
if you're not using something more
advanced like spring
or jee annotations or juice or what have
you so
we recommend that you use those other
things because they're typically more
powerful but if you just want to get off
the ground very quickly
there's this nice ionized support all of
the object graph configuration
beam config is in here and then there's
these three other sections
you can define static users static roles
and static url
filter chains of course
these are just users and their their
passwords these are any of the roles
that are
assigned to those particular users as
well as permissions assigned
or attributed to a role and again
i'm not going to get into all this stuff
too much because we're really here to
talk about sessions not so much
access control and security but one of
the cool things is that this url
section allows us to define filter
chains as a set of name value pairs
that i'll show in a little bit but it's
way easier to understand the flow of a
request through a filter chain
when you can see them list when you can
see them listed here
than having to figure out via all these
different definitions in web.xml
so we'll see an example of how that
looks in just a second
okay so we've got this configuration
mechanism
how do we build the components we need
to talk to cassandra
and then configure it within an
application
so there's two approaches as i mentioned
before there's
you can implement the session dao
interface yourself directly
to perform crud operations to your data
store
or you can use something that comes out
of the box with shiro
called an enterprise session or excuse
me enterprise
cash session dao and then you write a
cash manager
and so as part of its architectural
you know constructs shiro has a cache
manager that can be shared across
almost all the components in shiro so if
you write one cache manager
you can just plug it into the session
infrastructure and then all of your
sessions just
live permanently in the cache
um so for example if this was redis or
hazelcast all of the sessions could live
in the in that environment
but those aren't really persistent
environments and
you don't really want to lose sessions
if nodes go down so
cassandra can be an ideal approach so
cassandra is
not really a cache distributed cache
architecture because it's persistent
it's durable so we don't really need to
to go through this approach we're going
to write our own session dao
it's very easy to do though so what does
that look like
the only things that we really have to
care about when using cassandra
first session storage or at least things
that we have to write for shiro or
the session dao session id generator and
the the data store is already there it's
cassandra we don't have to do anything
with that
we don't need a session cache right s
cassandra is so
blazingly fast that you don't really
need an intermediate second layer cache
in between your application and
cassandra the read and and rights
of cassandra depending on your
deployment environment and the hardware
you're using
is typically extraordinarily fast such
that
you know you don't here here's a good
example
in our storm path uses a cassandra in
production
we also use hazelcast for certain things
for things unrelated to persistence but
a typical read
and we're all in an amazon ec2 by the
way a typical read from hazelcast will
take
around two milliseconds maybe maybe a
little bit more or less depending on the
on what's going on that day a typical
read from cassandra
might take three or two and a half
depending on
what's going on with the network so
because the the the speed is so quick
you don't really need this additional
infrastructure in place
um just for the purposes of of second
level cash for in front of cassandra so
we're going to we're going to ignore
this entirely we're not going to write
one we're not going to use one
the only thing that we have to worry
about are these two components um
and as i said before we'd probably write
like a time uid generator
just to insert things into cassandra
that way and then if you wanted to
insert or create your own secondary
indices you could then
filter by time you ids of when sessions
were created and kind of run reports and
all that fun stuff but it doesn't really
matter this could be a randomly
generated string
what whatever works but we'll use a time
uid generator and the session dao and
those are the only two things that we
have to configure
so we'll we'll implement our own
again we're not going to be uh using the
cache and session dao so
all the things that we have to do are
just override these methods do create do
read
update and delete there's this thing get
active sessions
that is necessary for many session dio
implementations
and that is used by the um the
validation scheduler
to make sure that all non-stop or
deleted sessions
make sure they're still alive and if
they're not alive it'll close out the
session and then delete it
you'll soon see that we're not actually
going to need this with cassandra though
so
this will be kind of a no op
implementation it'll return null or an
empty collection every time
and all you have to do is update or
override those those methods
so how do we enable this stuff in shiro
you know we've got a session dao we've
we got an implementation and i'll show
you guys the implementation a little bit
later if we have time
um but now we just need to tell shiro to
use it
so we've got a session manager again
we're running in a web container so
we'll use the web session manager
and we're going to tell shiro's security
manager this is again it's global
construct it's used in every there's
only
always one of these in every application
we're going to tell the security manager
that hey the session manager that i want
you to use for the app i want you to use
this web-based one
because we're in a web context so now
that we're using a web session manager
the next thing to do is configure the
session or the session dao for that
session manager
and this is pretty easy so as you guys
can kind of see
this poor man dependency injection is
kind of kicking in right we've got
on the left hand side of the equal sign
the identifier
and then a class to instantiate and then
these are just kind of
name value pairs that are set via
setters and we can do maps and other
things but
it's hopefully it's easy to understand
what's going on here
this object is just being assigned a
reference that we've defined up here
under the hood when we see some code a
little bit later
you'll see that all of this is using the
cassandra excuse me the datastax java
driver
and so this cluster factory is just a
wrapper that creates
a datastax driver cluster object
and returns it to shiro such that it can
be injected into other methods
for use later so we've acquired a
datastax
excuse me cluster object we were we have
a key space called shiro sessions
and we're going to stick it in this
column family called sessions
and so once we've defined the dao all we
have to do is just plug it into the
session manager
to tell the session manager hey i want
to use this object to perform the crot
operations for me
so anytime a crud operation occurs it's
going to be hitting cassandra now
because of this uh very simple dao
implementation
so we've got we've got the dao defined
how does
what does sessions actually look like in
cassandra and this is a sequel or cql3
kind of example
you know thrift works the same way but
since we're using the data stacks java
driver in our code base
uh which will be it's on github and i'll
give you guys a link afterwards
um we'll stick to cql3 to define the
table
so there's a sessions table there's a a
prime
a primary key which is the time uid in
this case there's a start and a stop
time stamp there's all access
lacks last access timestamp um
what the time out of that session is you
know 30 minutes or
one hour you know stuff that you
configure in your application
um there's there's a expired boolean
that can be set if you want to retain
the session for a long period of time
maybe you want to do historical
reporting
so maybe you don't delete the sessions
maybe maybe they stay in there but you
keep this expired flag to determine
whether or not
it's actively used the host from where
the session was initiated
and the serialized value here is really
just
serialized representation of the
attributes map so when you have a
session
like on in a web tier you call
session.getattribute.set attribute
this is really just a very efficiently
serialized
um version of that map and so shiro does
a lot of the serialization
itself via bit masks and other kind of
optimizations but
um this is just the raw output of that
of that attribute map
and of course because because it's a
blob um you want to make sure that this
isn't too big
um you know you can store pretty large
objects as column values and cassandra
so
cassandra's not going to really have
that much of a problem with it but the
bigger your session
is the more i o overhead it's going to
cause
and this is not this is a general
statement for all servant containers but
sessions should be very lightweight in
general
right you should only kind of have
pointers to objects and sessions
you shouldn't store entire object graphs
in the session themselves
because if you do it's going to be
serialized out to this blob
so you know instead of storing a user
object you would store
the user's primary key in the session
and then you get the key out and then
look up the user
and then maybe that's in second level
cache but the idea is keep this minimal
your i o overhead will be low and
it will be very fast with cassandra
so this is how this is kind of the
layout of how our our session objects
are going to be persisted
but if you guys remember back here
there's no session validation scheduler
here that's you that's usually a pretty
important thing for all session managers
but one of the cool things about
cassandra is that we don't need one
the reason why we don't need one is
because scandal has built into it this
really cool
concept of ttl time to live and so we
can use cassandra's time to live
to perform the same operations that
accession validation scheduler would do
right auto expire auto delete all the
records
or at least have the make the client
have the perception that they're
automatically removed
just based on the ttl setting so you
don't need the session validation
scheduler
it doesn't need to be operating as a
background process or a daemon thread
it doesn't need to be querying the data
store every so often to uh to reap
orphans
we can just let cassandra handle all
that for us
which is super cool so all we have to do
in this case is tell shiro's
session manager i don't want the session
validation scheduler to be enabled
because the data store is going to
handle this automatically
this is a very risky thing to turn to
false
unless the data store supports ttl
expirations so
because cassandra can we can turn that
off
and so now that that's off how do we
insert data or update sessions in the
data store
and it's just a very simple cql3
statement
right cassandra we call this an upsert
because there's really no difference
between an insert and an update
and so you can use a single query to
satisfy both insert and update
scenarios so here's what the query looks
like we're going to update the sessions
we're going to
use a particular ttl
and this is your session timeout value
also note that
this is not dollar sign notation it's
not part of cql if you're not familiar
with the cql syntax
this is just me kind of illustrating
where in the query you would put the
timeout
technically this should be another
question mark so it can be specified as
part of a prepared statement
but the idea here is that we're going to
update the sessions using the particular
ttl in this case the timeout is going to
be
whatever the number of seconds is times
30 minutes
by default so this is a this is the
number of seconds and 30 minutes by
default you can change it to be whatever
you want
and this can change per session so maybe
some sessions
are 30 minutes by default but other
sessions are five minutes or an hour so
just like the server container you can
you can control
which sessions timeout when and then it
updates all the fields that it needs to
update
serialized value of course and then the
id is your auto generated
identifier i should also kind of note
that
this last access timestamp thing is
pretty important so
in all servlet containers whenever a
request comes in
we've got to update the session to let
this or to let
the infrastructure know that this
session's still alive it's still active
and so what that means
for cassandra and this is really
important it's like one of the most
important parts of this talk is with
regards to how you set up and maintain
cassandra
that means every request that comes in
is going to read from the session
because it has to pull it from somewhere
right and also every single request is
going to result in a write to the
session table because
you've got to now update that session
entry to reflect
the last access timestamp all right this
has to happen all the time
and so with because with shiro you can
have a level one cache that kind of
does the reading and the writing
multiple times in a single thread
but at the end of that thread these
updates have to go out to cassandra
to make sure that the data store
reflects the current
persistent state of that of that session
what this means essentially is that
there's a one-to-one correlation between
reads and writes
for session activity using cassandra
so this might you know if you've used
cassandra for a while or
you've kind of been to some of the other
talks this might you know bring up a
question for you
what about tombstones every time that
you do a modification of a column value
or you you know you kind of delete
something it creates a tombstone
in cassandra how many people here know
what tombstones are
okay almost every how many people do not
know what tombstones are
there's a few people so when
cassandra persists data into ss tables
it's
it's kind of under the hood
representation of physical data
it never modifies that data in place ss
tables
are read only or excuse me append only
you can append data to them
but you're never allowed to change the
data that's in there so because it's an
append only data form
or a format or data storage mechanism
whenever you delete something it's
actually going to write
append to that ss table and say hey this
actually this value has changed
or it's removed so
reflect that whenever the customer or
the client rather
queries the data store and so because
there's tombstones
there's additional i o overhead every
time that you delete or update something
so if you have an append only kind of
write log cassandra is amazing for that
because there's almost no tombstones
being generated but when you do have
tombstones
generated as a result of an update or a
delete
this causes overhead for cassandra
because when it goes through compaction
to consolidate its ss tables it's got to
resolve these tombstones or these
deletion or these update markers
um and that there's io overhead in all
of that
and there's processing overhead and
doing that so the more tombstones you
have in a cluster
the more overhead you're going to have
so
there's a caveat with this how do we how
do we handle tombstones
in a relatively efficient way so that
things are that performance still stays
uh reasonable if you're going to be if
you're going to be doing all these
one-to-one reads and writes
the answer is is that we want to use a
level compaction strategy
so um and you want to change your gc
grace to make sure that the number of
tombstones
doesn't fill up your data store or
doesn't fill up cassandra
over time gc grace is by default 10 days
which is probably way too long for a
session store mechanism
so here we've actually cut it down to 24
hours it's actually probably even better
to go lower than this
if you can just realize that the lower
the gc grace
the higher the opportunity that data
might be lost if you if you don't go
through a repair process so
that's usually not really a problem in
practice with shiro
the sessions usually last much much
their lifespan is much smaller much
shorter than the gc grace
so it's almost never really an issue but
you want to keep this number relatively
low a day is probably good
i've talked to some of the cassandra
experts that
the cassandra expert meetup talks at the
um
the summit over the summer and they said
that this was probably more than fine
for for kind of this type of io
operations
and it's really important to use level
compaction strategy here instead of
size tiered compaction how many people
here do not know what the difference
between those two strategies are
okay we got a couple couple folks so
level compaction strategy
will actually compact ss tables into
larger ss tables that can be more
efficiently read
over time and it does it based on a
tiered strategy
so um you'll have like level level zero
ss tables will get compacted into a
level one ss table that's ten times the
size
i think this is five megs by default so
the next level below that is 50 megs the
next one below that's 500 megs
and what that allows cassandra to do is
kind of compact all the data
into ss tables that are read in
in order so it'll check l0 first before
it hits l1 before it hits l2 l3
and what that really amounts to is in a
very efficient
read result so if i have my data tiered
like this in multiple levels
i can check out one first
um the probability distribution on that
is that there's a 90
chance that i'm gonna find my data there
because of
it's most frequently acts or frequently
used if it's not there i'll fall back to
l1
there's a 90 chance it's going to be
there and so you get this really
efficient
read distribution to make sure your data
is accessible and very very quick
reads are very very fast because
tombstones however
being created due to the right
this will incur a higher i o overhead
for cassandra
so you have to be aware of this your io
io
overhead is at least doubled if not more
than what size tiered compaction is all
about size tiered
will compact ss tables based on size so
if they hit
a certain file size limit it'll start
going through the compaction process
the key pro the key issue here with
tombstones and changes with size tiered
is those changes those markers can be
spread out over multiple files
so in order to read a single record
cassandra might have to read
two three four ten different ss tables
right and that's a very inefficient
process for things that have to be read
on every request
so do not use size tiered compaction if
you're using sessions for
for for cassandra definitely stick to
leveled
just again be aware that your i o
overhead is going to be doubled that of
normal workload
so and this is kind of true in general
not just for sessions the more that your
application reads from a table
the more it will benefit from from level
compaction the more that it writes or
appends
the more size tiered will benefit from
it just be aware the fragmentation that
occurs on
on size tiered
what about row caching people ask you
know hey should i enable row caching
in order to make my session reads even
faster and the answer is you don't you
don't really need it
it's not really that beneficial ss table
your s's table
again via all the off-heap storage
that's in in use
uh for the later later uh editions of
cassandra
odds are very high or the ss table is
already going to be in operating system
page cache you don't need a row cash
it's
there's only very very specific
situations under which you would
probably ever need to
to enable a row cash and if you
are debating whether or not you need to
do that my best answer for you is to
talk to the data stacks team
you know there's so many minutiae
involved as to whether or not it's a
good idea that they're really the only
people that are qualified to answer that
question the vast majority of time
you're never going to need row cash
key cash however is very important right
to cash the row keys
and that's enabled by default in 1.2 and
above so you don't really have to worry
about that
11 40 okay i got this is actually the
final slide i wanted to give you guys a
demo
apache shiro has a demo web app and i've
already configured it
to point to cassandra
here it is it's on github you can go to
my page check it out
it's literally you get clone you change
into the directory
fire up cassandra then you run mvn jetty
run and you'll see
a full web application that's running on
top of cassandra using apache shiro for
session clustering
everything works beautifully i also did
some performance testing on this i can't
again i don't have time to demo but it's
extraordinarily fast you can
you can easily handle concurrent
operations for a hundred thousand
different sessions
um doing nothing but io i think it only
takes like maybe 60 seconds
to run a full test i have eight threads
running each thread
will create a session read the session
update the session delete the session
and then do another read
to make sure that it's gone it does five
of those those query operations against
cassandra
each five of those operations are
executed by eight different threads
concurrently
100 or 100 000 times and the whole thing
takes
less than 60 seconds so like the ability
to support hundred thousand or five
hundred thousand or a million concurrent
sessions is extraordinarily easy you
could probably do it on a single box if
your uh your your scheduler was was
efficient enough for the cpu that you
had was efficient enough so
um highly recommend doing this storm
path
obviously we run cassandra in production
and we do this we support
all the sessions that we have to support
with no problem at all so
um check out the code if you have any
questions hit me up at uh
on twitter or access our website we are
most definitely hiring
cassandra engineers if you're interested
in a job working with cassandra and
storm and real-time processing with
kafka
um give us a shout out and and or come
talk to me but
that's it i'm out of time thank you so
much for uh for
attending if you have any questions
maybe i've got time for it